stranger things has one of the best
ensembles tv has ever seen but the show
could have been very different if any of
the talented cast weren't rejected one
too many times ready to find out who was
crazy enough not to hire them number one
the film industry is a lot like game of
thrones in its own way you get no's a
lot on those before you get yes millie
bobby brown auditioned to play a
character in game of thrones the
rejection was so hard on her she nearly
quit acting that's kind of when i was
like oh this is really difficult she
moved away from los angeles and back to
england and everything one of my last
kind of goals at this was netflix show
called montauk aka stranger things we're
pretty sure every time we hear of an
actor making it big it was right after a
disappointing audition that almost made
them quit i was i think i was just very
disheartened by the rejection so we
wonder if there's a mindset thing that
happens either they just don't care
anymore and the nerves go away and they
give one awesome audition or they've
built up the story in their head that it
was the end but really they weren't even
close to being ready to give up montauk
was definitely the one that kind of gave
me that hope of doing it all again every
audition may feel like the last one in
an industry that beats you down so much
number two jaime always has been drawn
to the supernatural stuff jamie campbell
bower auditioned for edward and twilight
but was rejected he wound up playing
caius in new moon though to the end of
the series caius was one of the members
of the valturi given the way the series
has aged and seeing how robert pattinson
still has a hard time shaking the
sparkles it was probably in jaime's best
interest to not have played the lead he
did of course play the lead j sweyland
in the mortal instruments which had a
very similar tone to twilight
number three you've gotta wonder what
happened noah schnapp auditioned to play
the boy in wonder he lost the role to
jacob trombley who's just a bit younger
noah also initially auditioned for mike
in stranger things but landed will
buyers instead so if you think he and
finn look similar it's because he was a
runner-up to play the lead
number four listen joseph don't beat
yourself up too much i was up for
spider-man the guy who got the role was
quite literally too perfect for it
nobody else compared nobody joseph quinn
auditioned to play spider-man we all
know who he lost the role to but the
good news is that joseph remains
optimistic about his audition still wait
to hear
who wants to be the one to tell him
number five a team up of wolverine and
11 would be epic millie bobby brown
auditioned to play the little girl in
x-men's logan she lost out on the part
to the slightly younger spanish british
actor daphne keane
number six we're entering into the
corrupt side of hollywood for a second
david harbour auditioned for fred dukes
aka blob in x-men origins wolverine
after being told they needed a bigger
guy for the part in the audition harbor
jokingly picked up his shirt and said i
got your blob right here arbor admitted
that the director said to him afterwards
david look you're wonderful we really
think you're just a great actor we're
just concerned we're really concerned
harbour said why what's your concern i'm
good to go i'm available let's do this
their response no it's just you lifted
up your shirt and we saw the we're just
a little worried about your health but
harbor sass was the best part he shot
back wait a minute dude pause for one
second you're telling me i'm too fat to
play the blob that's awesome instead
they stuck a ton of prosthetics onto
kevin durand
number seven star wars and origin story
robert englund went out for an audition
for a part of a surfer in apocalypse now
he was rejected for being too old but at
that audition he'd heard about how star
wars was casting for han solo and he
went and auditioned for that he was
rejected again this time for being too
young but you know who he lived with one
mark hamill who he'd told about the
audition and that's how the world got
it's luke skywalker number eight maybe
finn is aiming to do movies and shows in
every decade finn wolfhard's had a few
tough auditioning experiences he was
genuinely heartbroken when he didn't
land a part in jonah hill's movie mid
90s we imagine he auditioned for the
role of stevie or maybe rubin the other
troubling audition for the actor was the
role of brah sound effect 2. hi i'm
jeremy roger smith and i'm auditioning
for the role of bra sound effect 2. we
heard they went with jeremy roger smith
instead
in case the joke is lost on you finn is
jeremy roger smith number nine winona's
a leading lady and she's always been
aiming for the best of the best when it
comes to characters winona ryder's been
very open about her many rejections does
that make her a bad actor not by any
means she's just the one who talks about
the fails she was a rising star at the
time of her audition for rose and
titanic in which kate winslet beat her
for despite being more of a noob she
lost a role in shakespeare in love to
her friend gwyneth paltrow just a couple
of years later the two were desperate to
be in chicago together as roxy and velma
well they lost out to renee zellweger
and catherine zeta-jones
number 10 did everybody audition for
mike first noah schnapp wasn't the only
one who auditioned for the lead gayton
matarazzo was originally asked to
audition too we can only imagine how
different the show would be if he'd have
played the lead instead but we just
loved dustin and wouldn't change him for
the world number eleven here's another
reason why all the male actors kinda
look similar joe kiri originally
auditioned to play jonathan then sent a
tape in for the role of steve it was a
much better fit if we do say so
ourselves hey maybe the characters are
all second cousins
whoa whoa this is crazy hawkins is a
pretty small place it's possible number
12. it isn't very often actors do
multiple shows and movies together in a
lifetime i actually auditioned for the
goalkeepers you were in there yeah you
did we did charlie heaton auditioned for
the goldfinch we imagine for the role of
theodore decker as it went to an actor
of a similar age ansel elgort finn
wolfhard was in this movie as well yeah
and i was wishing that you could have
gone
number thirteen maybe if you're just
precious enough they will ignore the
fact you're only a single threat sadie
sink auditioned for matilda on broadway
which was a bold move because i am not a
dancer priya ferguson auditioned for
annie but she can't sing there are some
things you can lie about on a resume
like your ability to roller skate or
your sewing skills but if you can't sing
and you're going out for a musical all
we can say is break a leg preferably for
real you will save yourself a ton of
embarrassment number 14. yes she's been
so vocal about her rejections we had to
split it up into two parts she was
turned down for the role of marla singer
in fight club which went to helena
bonham carter she lost out on the lead
to kristen stewart in snow white and the
huntsman and she also auditioned for a
role in almost famous it was
i mean it was definitely overwhelming
well she's famous now too famous even
though these snooty casting directors
couldn't see talent if it punched them
in the face just kidding there's enough
room in hollywood for everybody and we
love winona's role in stranger things
number 15. the hustle is real and
rejection is even more common for
writers than actors they're not actors
but the duffer brothers were rejected by
15 different studios before netflix
picked up stranger things we bet those
other studios are kicking themselves in
the butt now while rejection is more
common than booking a role in hollywood
it's still interesting to hear where our
favorite actors didn't land apart it
inspires us to never give up do you have
an inspirational story about a time you
almost gave up but powered through
motivate us all in the comments and
thanks for hanging out with us here at
the things